نبدا همم طبعا بهذا الخبر الذي همم يعني
اعلنت عنه الشرطه الاسرائيليه ومقتل مواطن
همم من الاقليه العربيه كما قيل بعض النصب
كاملا دعينا في حيثيات وملابسات ما جرحهم
بالفعل بحسب بيان الشرطه الاسرائيليه
وصلتنا نسخه عنها البيان يقول بان شابا
فلسطينيا يدعم همم اتصل هاتفيا بمركز
الشرطه الاسرائيليه في كفر قاسم وابلغ عن
وجود حادث عنف ويتحرك الشرطه باتجاه
المكان الاتصال
وعندما وصلت الشرطه الى المكان اشهر بحسب
بيان الشرطه نعيم سلاحا بوجه افراد الشرطه
وبعد ذلك حاول تنفيذ عمليه الدهس بسيارته
كانت بحوزته همم فورا اشاره لا السلاح تمت
عمليه اطلاق نار
ادى الى همم ارتقائه وبطبيعه الحال في
بيان الشرطه
قال بان سرعه رد الشرطه الاسرائيليه على
هذه العمليه حاله دون وقوعه عمليه واسعه
وعمليه همم كبيره بطبيعه الحال هذا هو
الحلفيات الحادث من الجانب الاسرائيلي على
الصعيد الفلسطيني
الشاب الفلسطيني من اراضي 48
فندت الروايه الاسرائيليه وروايه الشرطه
واعتبرت بحسب تصريحات لها بان افراد
الشرطه قاموا باعدام ابنهم عن مسافه صفر
ونرفت ان يكون قد حاول تنفيذ عمليات الدهس
بطبيعه الحل كانت عمليه تمشيط في المنطقه
على الفور ثم اعتقال بحسب الشرطه
الاسرائيليه همم شاب واثنين من اشقائه
وابن عمه لمعرفه اذا كان لديه معلم بنيه
لتنفيذ مثل هذه العمليه